are you a STONER do you want to make
love with a STONER well guess what there
is a new website just for you that's
right Los Angeles marijuana entrepreneur
Miguel Lozano has launched the world's
first marijuana dating site it is called
my 420 mate calm and let's take a look
at the website right there so it's a
very fancy website I'm very impressed
with a website I'm just gonna read a
little bit about it Miguel says I was
trying to change the stereotype of the
average cannabis user everyone uses the
word STONER but it's a lifestyle there's
a lot more to it than that we have
teachers chefs and computer techs who
enjoy the benefits of marijuana that guy
I bet you could smoke it pretty sure you
could smoke his hair just a little bit
more so far there's about 11,000 users
but the founders said they're adding
about a hundred new people a day and the
profiles are for people from marijuana
legal states like California Colorado
and Washington okay all right you know
we talked about dating apps all the time
we talked about weed all the time this
just seems natural I think there's
something kind of funny about like I
smoke weed I gotta be with someone with
that smokes weed usually I think if you
smoke weed you're you find yourself
around people that smoke weed and you
might find somebody that you want to
sleep with I mean despite what my hair
says I've never smoked them I'm not in
the community but I mean it's I think
it's I think it's useful because willing
to take a live experience just from
friends not even the dating part of it
but there's a discomfort sometimes with
oh you don't smoke you like are you sure
I was at my friend's house isn't in
college and he's like hey Jay you think
it's cool but smoke I was like [ __ ]
manage your house if I have a problem
with it I should leave you know so
there's there's a yeah there's they
didn't want to ruffle any tail feathers
or above anyone else with their weed and
oh my god is your closing a smell like
it and I think there's a comfort level
and it's a it's a life community
lifestyle thing that everyone that's not
just smoking and passing the [ __ ] out
there's so many different things about
it and I've learned on them because I
have a lot of pothead friends yeah
trying to be in
it's a comfort thing yeah you know now
that we have legal marijuana here
medicinal marijuana which basically if
you have oh my shoulder hurts now you
can get weed here in California although
it is federally still illegal Obama
keeps saying that they're not going to
enforce this stuff but just in West
Hollywood where I live this week they it
they raided another dispensary so the
feds are still not playing ball the way
they imply that they are but what I've
noticed is as it's legal here I go to
parties there could be a lot of people
smoking weed and it nobody cares there
isn't even the slightest stigma attached
to it anymore and to me it's almost sort
of like the gay marriage thing that it
slowly started happening and then people
were like oh nothing changed
there was the devil didn't appear and we
didn't get more earthquakes or
hurricanes and we're all gonna be okay
so what do you think but you know I
think we're lucky because this is the
California Way where we tend gay
marriage is pretty darn cool I mean I
went to college in the Midwest where he
said gosh darn to the wrong person I
mean they were it was an uproar for that
whole site you couldn't go to that
section of the room anymore for the rest
of the night personally I would like to
know if someone's you know into weed
because I want to know who can't get it
up at night I wanna know I want to know
who we're not gonna have to have a
conversation know there's my breath I
partake recreationally but it's not my
thing so I but I have terrible glaucoma
you have the bracelet yeah I don't wear
it obviously on the show but but you did
back lane and of several pretty severe
medical man if it makes you happy Sheryl
Crow is there something funny about that
there's so there's a weed website now
you don't have an alcoholics website
right so there's something there that
but does that show you maybe that weed
is better somehow right if there was a
website for alcohol I don't say
alcoholics but just a I drink a lot you
know website people would think that's
really weird this one doesn't strike me
as Purple's bars
because they're all closeted they can't
actually date the same gender
I know interesting yeah that's the
alcohol okay now that that's all been a
week is it fixed now I've not had yeah
how many I know they got into a lawsuit
or so they're run by Christians I don't
know if they don't even checked in
recently on eHarmony but yeah but really
quick this only work with weed if there
was a booze one there and I could have
illegal drugs I guess they can't do it
that way it's because like you said it's
being accepted even people act like it's
not accepted oh my god you smoke really
in the back of the head they're not
afraid of this person they don't think
this person is gonna run it like start a
fight with them you know there's there's
still the fear without really any real
evidence behind it you're like man you
smoke you must do what no cuz before I
was clearly you a cuddle another blanket
you would hide it you were the readings
with these people wait you freakin alert
they're out there on the beach wandering
around any one of their hand no that's
right that's right